Brain games promise to enhance your mind with
stimulating fun.
So what’s to stop some maniac from downloading
all of them, getting a sidekick named Pinky,
and taking over the world?
As it turns out…
Brain games.
Hello mind craft enthusiasts, Julian here
for DNews.
Computer-based cognitive-training software,
or brain games, are a growing market with
over 10 thousand in the app store.
They promise boosted problem-solving abilities
that will be long lasting.
They claim to help sustain your memory in
your twilight years.
Some even say they can make you good at math!
All in exchange for few minutes of play a
day.
But nearly 70 scientists have signed an open
letter from the Stanford Center for Longevity
saying they’re not so sure.
The letter explains that playing these brain
games does make you better at something; playing
brain games.
The same way that playing a lot of flappy
bird makes you better at unbridled rage!
But getting better at a very specific task
doesn’t translate to broad cognitive improvements.
The letter also explains that when players
get better at a game, usually it’s because
they’ve developed a better strategy, and
I can attest firsthand to that.
One of my favorite “brain games” involves
combining numbered tiles to get the highest
score.
I only got that damn 2048 tile when I changed
up my strategy, not by playing so much my
planning and spatial reasoning improved.
But surely playing these games can’t hurt
right?
Well the letter goes on to explain that the
time spent playing these games could be better
used doing things known to promote a healthy
brain.
Things like reading, exercise, or being sociable.
So the opportunity cost of playing a repetitive
game with narrow benefits may make them not
worth your time.
If you’d like to learn about more myths
about your brain, like the oft-quoted stat
that we use 10% of it, Anthony has a video
on that here.
How are you making your brain healthier?
What do you do to get it jump-started?
Let us know in the comments, and I’ll see
you next time on DNews